welcome back to street talk unplugged
this is your host tim scarf i have covid
this week so sorry if my voice is a
little bit hoarse
i'm gonna do a little bit of
housekeeping to start things off now if
you want to jump straight into the
interview then check out the table of
contents and just skip right ahead we're
doing our first community event on
discord this wednesday andre zakarovich
is presenting a session on discrete
program synthesis and then we're going
to have a q a and discussion afterwards
so it's kicking off at about 5 pm uk
time nearly 500 people joined our
discord in the first week or so which
just blew my mind
um we we already have the beginnings
actually have a really exciting discord
community taking shape we've got some
amazing people in there so now's the
time to jump in and say hello
at the beginning of the year we decided
to experiment with releasing a couple of
audio only podcasts
called unplugged where we don't spend
much if any time preparing beforehand
the main difference between mlst and
other podcasts has always been the
prodigious amount of preparation that we
put in before the shows and um it was
strangling our output a little bit so i
guess we just wanted to do the counter
factual you know run an experiment and
see what would have happened if we
didn't suffer from the curse of
perfectionism
mlst is a think tank as you've probably
noticed by now we don't just invite a
bunch of random people on to monologue
or pitch their startup we get straight
into the weeds and we have a deep
technical discussion
with our guests perhaps the main
difference with the unplugged shows has
been that the dialogue has been a little
bit more open-ended and accessible we
did change the plan a little bit though
as you probably noticed we decided to
publish these unplugged shows on youtube
as well and so the video from the
interview
has gone up there you know i think some
of you are really passionate about
youtube being your primary uh delivery
platform and i personally have always
been a huge fan of youtube myself i
think it just adds so much value being
able to see the facial expressions and
the visual cues
to be honest i've been really surprised
at how flowy and natural these
conversations have been and according to
the analytics the engagement on the
conversational segments has been higher
on these shows than our traditional ones
so maybe it's just due to their informal
you know kind of open-ended and
accessible nature i'm not sure but um we
have had a lot of feedback that our
content is quite hard to understand and
quite academic in nature
and you know the detailed preparation we
did probably only serve to make the
shows more opaque to people
we do pride ourselves on being really
technical
mlst is almost certainly the most
technical podcast on ml but there's a
sweet spot to be found somewhere as you
probably noticed we do try and zoom out
and we focus on some deep ideas and
themes you know which come up over many
shows so big one is the dichotomy
between discrete and continuous for
example
now the show right here this one was
actually the very first unplugged show
which we filmed at the beginning of
january listening back to it now it's
probably my favorite one there is
actually one other one which is amazing
which hopefully we can get
approval to release um there's a bit of
a backstory there but uh this one's
really really good and i think it's
because of the incredible rapport and
friendship we had with walid to sabbath
we delayed the release of it because we
mentioned benjio in the introduction and
we didn't want to spook him off he
accepted our invitation back in january
to come on the show but i'll explain
more about that in a minute
but yeah to finish the thread on
unplugged this is an experiment we
probably will run it until april and
then we're gonna pivot and we're gonna
make some pedagogical content kind of
three blue one brown style
uh content without any invited guests
and we'll see how that performs but so
far unplugged has been pretty successful
i would say
now trigger warning this episode is very
critical of deep learning walid sabha is
probably the
uh you know if you think gary marcus is
a critic of deep learning walid sabha is
one notch up
um if you're not up for that just skip
this episode right we really want to
capture diverse opinions in the ai
landscape and i'm not just saying that
look on our front page right we've just
interviewed two of the three godfathers
of deep learning in the past five videos
or so personally speaking my salary does
not depend on a subscription to any
particular viewpoint in ai which is
perhaps the main reason we have the
freedom to explore i really love
diversity of thought in general and
that's why you'll see us making content
on loads of ideas some of which i don't
even subscribe to like ai alignment
we're planning a big show on that now
that my mate conor leahy has
you know found his way to london
um it's really important to hear
opinions from people outside of our
circles even if we don't want to hear
them or we don't like the people
espousing them unfortunately because of
the tribalism in our community many
folks have refused our invitations to
come on mlst and the couple even told me
straight to my face it was because we
had pedro domingos on the show and they
didn't want to be tarred by association
um it might also be because yannick has
been quite outspoken on ai risk and
identity politics and ethics but this is
the really annoying thing about
podcaster stan right it's really hard to
get genuinely diverse views on the same
platform this is why so many podcasts
become more polarized on the one hand or
just completely bland on the other even
some of the podcasters i really love
like sam harris they've just become
really entrenched in recent years right
sam doesn't invite anyone on that he
doesn't agree with anymore we've had and
by the way sam's an interesting case i
mean i i don't really agree i don't
really agree with really much of
anything he says but i just love
listening to him for some reason he's
got such a soothing voice um but anyway
as i said he doesn't invite anyone on
that he doesn't agree of anymore we've
had a couple of comments saying that
we've invited too many well-educated
white guys on the show well to be honest
most of the diverse folks just ignore
our invitations i can assure you we've
actually invited most of the
diverse big names in ml i don't feel
it's appropriate to say their names but
you can probably guess who they are we
are inviting more
i'm extremely open-minded right and i
hope that we can have more diverse
guests and topics in the future
i don't want to mislead you i'm actually
dead against cancer culture and identity
politics but it's not a hill that i want
to die on keith and yannick would die on
it all day long but i would rather
appease people and attract interesting
guests from my podcast rather than
alienate them over an ideological point
of principle i didn't even want to use
the term cancer culture in the
introduction because it means you'll
instantly put me in a political box
right i genuinely think that sunlight is
the best disinfectant for bad ideas but
i also think that there are very few
issues which you should be genuinely
cancelled for inciting or committing
acts of violence seems like an obvious
red line to me but it's not clear where
the boundaries should lie
the situation in ukraine has really put
a lot of things in perspective for me in
the last week or so
now i know pedro got himself into a lot
of trouble on twitter recently over
comments he made about women and
positive discrimination in the workplace
he was making some inferences about
study and many highly respected
academics argued that he made an
incorrect inference based on the study
now i didn't even read the study but
based on the uniform denunciation of
pedro's comments i assume he got it
wrong this time
but here's the thing if i actually
believed that pedro was a misogynist or
a racist i wouldn't have invited him on
mlst just because i don't believe in
cancer culture in principle doesn't mean
that i wouldn't invite him on mlst
regardless right what's really going on
here is that there's a bunch of people
who hate pedro's political views and
they're trying to censor him by
deliberately mischaracterizing his views
uh anyway how did we get here
yes so we were talking about deep
learning bashing which is only slightly
less ideological than identity politics
by the way deep learning is a
revolutionary and fascinating technology
but it's also got some glaring pitfalls
that even the best in the field don't
want to acknowledge because their
careers depend on maintaining the
illusion for as long as possible the
immediate future will probably be a
hybrid of neural networks and symbolic
approaches and it will probably be here
faster than you realize
[Music]
dr walid subber is an old school
polymath he has a background in
cognitive psychology linguistics
philosophy computer science and logic
he's now a senior scientist at sorcero
now walid is perhaps the most outspoken
critic
of birtology which is to say trying to
solve the problem of natural language
understanding with the application of
large statistical language models
wally thinks that this approach is
cursed to failure because it's analogous
to memorizing infinity with a large hash
table
actually wally thinks that the various
appeals to infinity by some deep
learning researchers
are visible
now um it's not hyperbolic to say that
mlps are like locality sensitive hashing
tables
i mean that's precisely what dr randall
balestrio from meta ai research
demonstrated in his spline theory of
neural networks paper
yazaman rosegui from uc irvine recently
published work apparently indicating
that this is indeed the case in large
language models like gpt j
with respect to their ability to
multiply numbers together zero shot she
demonstrated that their performance was
linearly correlated with the term
frequency and the training corpus
strongly indicating that the models had
just memorized the answer well turns out
that we're going to be interviewing
yazaman
and also her phd supervisor samia singh
in the next couple of weeks so keep an
eye out for that wally has made a name
for himself railing against the apparent
lack of any understanding in the latest
state-of-the-art statistical language
models
and also what he perceives to be
hyperbole and intransigence in the deep
learning community
now there was a paper recently released
called the defeat of the winograd
schemer challenge by vid koshijan
and also with some of the usual suspects
like gary marcus and ernest davis at out
talking about the perils of metric
optimization and nlp using the winograd
schema challenge
now um the winograd schema challenge was
designed to be a good proxy for common
sense reasoning they were first proposed
by hector levesque in 2011 and by about
2019 a number of these transformers
models were getting better than 90
accuracy on some of these problems
now an example of a winograd schema is
as follows
the woman stopped taking the pills
because they
were pregnant
or carcinogenic
now does the pronoun they
refer to the pills
or the women
well it changes depending on the final
word being pregnant or carcinogenic
cosijan etau pointed out that the
naturalness of the winograd schema task
is particularly striking as compared to
many other natural language tasks such
as benchmarks right you know it makes it
seem
compelling as a powerful test of human
understanding and this stands in stark
contrast with the other tasks such as
considering the entailment between two
sentences we're identifying segments of
a text which answers a question or maybe
word analogies or even predicting the
next word in a sequence of words you
know which is the
the task in traditional language
modelling now wally thinks that the
biggest problem that we need to solve in
nlp is the so-called missing information
problem
which is that we don't say everything
that we mean
we need to reason and extrapolate to
fill in the missing blanks and neural
networks only extrapolate when given
explicit handcrafted priors for a
particular invariance or hybrid
architectures which effectively generate
additional training data to fill in
those blanks
recently released an article titled ai
cannot ignore symbolic logic and here's
why
the article was even reposted by
professor ian lacoon and professor yoshi
abengio
two of the godfathers of deep learning
that we've just recently had on now uh
jan made it abundantly clear that he
disagreed with the article almost 100
percent and walid led with a quote from
yoshi of engio joshua once said that
deep learning as it is now has made huge
progress in perception but it hasn't yet
delivered on systems which can discover
high-level representations the kind of
concepts that we use in language
humans are able to use these high-level
concepts to generalize in powerful ways
and that's something that even babies
can do but machine learning is very bad
at
end quote now that of course was music
to waleed's er ears right walid is a
traditional symbolist he thinks that
without symbolic and logical reasoning
we'll never build something which even
partially resembles artificial
intelligence
benji has actually been much more open
to
discussing the limitations of deep
learning as opposed to hinton for
example
he recently said that very soon deep
learning will be able to do anything
now um bengio responded on linkedin
saying that he thought that there was a
misunderstanding in walid's post arising
from the sincere but incorrect belief
that it's not possible for neural
networks to do symbolic manipulation
although unfortunately he didn't explain
how exactly he thought they could
he agreed with walid on the importance
of symbolic manipulation and asserted
that indeed the human brain must be
doing it somehow and that he thought it
would be essential for improving the
state of our state of the art and ai
primarily because of its importance in
abstraction or abstract extrapolation
now um we demonstrated comprehensively
on our lacun show that mlps can be
thought of as locality sensitive hashing
tables now let's not forget that all
neural network architectures have an mlp
back end
neural networks decompose an input space
into an exponentially large number of
nested polyhedra which represent volumes
of statistical generalization around the
training data they are storage buckets
they're not computational devices right
so saying that neural networks can
perform symbolic manipulation to me is
roughly equivalent to the statement that
locality sensitive hashing tables can
perform symbolic manipulation
the most simple way to understand this
is that the representational capacity of
a neural network is fixed
but if you take the symbolic um quantity
x equals y squared it's an infinite
table
right if you watched our episode on
geometric deep learning you would know
that all of the deep learning
architectures get around this problem by
constructing inductive priors which
basically replicate information in
respect of an invariance so for example
translational symmetries and in cnns um
what they do is they kind of replicate
this information into those buckets of
the hash table on the mlp back end
during inference or training
now benjio said that he thought a
particular kind of deep learning
architecture with an appropriate system
two inductive bias would give us what's
needed
and it's the core of his research
program actually most importantly he
doesn't think that solution will be a
simple hybrid of symbolic methods and
neural networks where we just glue them
together with some high-level interface
now benjio thinks that the main reason
this won't work is because you need to
have end-to-end learning and that you
need to have some kind of system two for
reasoning and planning now this is where
it gets really interesting now i'm
quoting directly now
in order to scale
system two forms of reasoning and
planning we need to have a powerful but
implicit form of search that system one
neural networks can provide like an
alphago for example what i like to call
the imagination machine which
spontaneously pops up reasonably good
solutions paths reasonings and
explanations in our conscious mind
without the need for explicit search
end quote
now benjio is of course talking about
g-flow nets and you can watch the show
we did on g-flow nets and indeed the
interview that we conducted with him it
was really really cool but to
contextualize this a little bit though
all neural networks have an mlp back end
which is a locality sensitive hashing
table the only reason these models can
extrapolate is if we create an inductive
prior to pack all of the information
into those buckets of this hash table
the complexity here depends on how
structured and how large the functional
space is walid sabha argues that
language is not amenable to any
statistical modelling methods because
it's infinitely large discrete and
unstructured from a statistical point of
view
now coming back to wally's article he
says that the problem deep learning
aficionados have in admitting symbolic
and logical reasoning is that all of
this will make neural networks just one
of the tools which can be used at
low-level tasks such as perception and
pattern recognition while symbolic and
logical reasoning will have the
supremacy of modeling human-like
high-level reasoning
now um and by that i mean the kind that
we're using complex problem-solving
tasks and language understanding now for
example walid says that there are many
high-level templates which underlie most
of how we function in the world
templates which are universally valid
across cultures and ages and individual
experiences
walid argues that the universality and
application of these templates on
concepts of specific types precludes
learning them bottom up from data
because one we cannot and we're not
allowed to learn them differently and
two that there's just no time for a
child to learn all of these common sense
naive physics templates bottom up
although their behavior by the age of
three clearly shows that they've
mastered all of these templates
if you say to a five-year-old kid that
his toy is in the bag and the bag is now
in his room the child will know that his
toy is now in the room try telling the
five-year-old kid that the toy is still
here
it's not like this daniel kahneman view
of the world where we allow significant
irrationality when you look at our
low-level conception of reality there's
no surprise there are no deviations
think of transitivity if you ask your
child to put the camera in a briefcase
and it didn't fit because the briefcase
was too small try telling the child to
put the camera in a smaller briefcase
wally actually told us that he did this
experiment with his kids
walid asserts that everyone acquires
exactly the same abstract categories or
templates
it's like they're a gift to us from
physical reality itself
they are primitive abstract categories
of our physical reality and they evolved
into our dna now i did challenge walid
on whether the progressive acquisition
of these abstract templates into our dna
could itself be akin to a learning
process rather than the binary
acquisition which he describes
and um that did leave him a little bit
lost for words but walid assures any
kind of learning he thinks that there is
a platonic configuration of templates
given to us from reality and we can only
discover them
his main objection to them being learned
is that they cannot be learned
differently and thus they cannot be the
result of our own individual experiences
he thinks that they are laws of nature
which were implanted into our dna that
you know we need them to be able to
function properly walid does not like
the notion that knowledge can be learned
progressively or that it can be learned
differently it's very much a binary
thing to him you know walid gave me the
example of a toy going out of sight of a
four-year-old they would know that it
did not disappear but it must be
somewhere else right because they know
that some physical objects must be
located somewhere the logic here is even
more sophisticated and operates on
objects in a typed ontology so while the
toy must be somewhere
if it was not completely destroyed
well actually this isn't true of all
physical objects right i mean for
example
if the object that went out of sight was
an apple
we might hesitate to conclude that it
you know must be somewhere else because
the apple might have been eaten so we
have this very sophisticated logic that
symbolically quantifies over objects of
a certain type
each with its exceptions and rules
all of this is going on in the head of a
child incidentally these high-level
templates are mostly employed
using neither induction nor deduction
but abduction right which is to say
inference to the best explanation which
is for the most part ignored in
artificial intelligence research today
walid says that when confronted with a
new situation the relevant template is
instantiated right or filled out with
specific objects of the appropriate type
in a way which is consistent with the
overall logic of the template
right for the best explanation of where
the toy is given that the bag containing
the toy was moved to the bedroom and
absence any exceptions is that the toy
must now be in the room if there are no
common sense templates which have a
logic consistent with our physical world
how does a child learn all of that
bottom up from data by the age of two or
three walid thinks that all of the
replies from empiricists and bottom-up
theorists to these questions end up
being no more than hand waving and the
best example of how autonomous driving
technology where these high-level naive
physics templates are essential failed
when it ignored this part of our
cognitive apparatus all of this which
allows us to behave properly according
to the logic of the world we live in
also applies to language in his article
he gives many examples right so one of
them is the loves template walid is
showing how these high-level symbolic
templates can blow up exponentially with
instantiations of instances that are of
the appropriate type
let's look at a couple of examples
my cousin loves playing the guitar where
the entity here is an activity
my sister loves glamour where the entity
is equality
my neighbor loves grandma sue where the
entity is a person
the boy that comes here every morning
wearing a red cap loves ac dc and the
entity there is a social group you can
probably see where this is going when
you have the abstract templates you can
extrapolate into an infinite number of
possible situations and experience space
wally thinks that we are born with these
templates begged in and that we become
aware of them or they come to life when
we first see instantiations of them
walid concludes his article by saying
that none of these observations are new
most of this was already observed and
known and argued for even proven
since the early 1980s and he suggests
reading the philosopher jerry fodor
perhaps starting with concepts where
cognitive science went wrong and having
another good look at the cognitive
science literature with an open mind as
an antidote to the current deep learning
malays
so anyway now i give you
dr walid sabha
so wally you brought up this um this
problem that i thought was kind of
interesting and it goes like this
consider the following two sentences
a the trophy did not fit in the suitcase
because it was too small
and b the trophy did not fit in the
suitcase because it was too big
now we as as human beings you know we
know where to assign small and big
whether it should belong to the uh the
trophy or the suitcase but we do that
because we have this this kind of extra
context
so for example i know that
typically things go inside suitcases
like trophies not the other way around
and i also know that in order for
something to spatially fit into
something
it has to be smaller than the other
thing so there's a spatial relationship
that i'm aware of this kind of context
and i think um you made the point that
look if you just look at statistically
something like a neural network
transformer it's going to find that
small and big are virtually
statistically identical and it's going
to fail to do this type of reasoning
that we can do as people but my question
is
it seems to me like that knowledge about
you know how things fit into another
thing or that typically things go inside
suitcases
i could glean
statistical knowledge about that from
the corpus
you know couldn't i i mean where where
does that kind of go wrong that that
context could still be
learned statistically
okay uh
first the
argument someone might argue and i know
someone like tim
has hinted at that argument that small
and big
although
just word embedding kind of similarity
they might be very close
in the wider context there are
techniques where you can take their
position into consideration and
and
they and their contribution to the
overall
meaning
would be significant although
statistically both are
as likely in the same context yes you
can increase
your
uh statistical significance between them
slightly
and and i and i underline slightly so
from them being almost identical they
become in a wider context with attention
and transformers they become slightly
distinguishable not much but that
having said that we can we can get into
the technicalities of that
that is not the main problem here
actually it's not about
it's not only because small and big are
statistically similar
the problem is much bigger than that and
here's what the problem is
again it goes back to infinity going
learning from instances is theoretically
plausible if i can live 200 billion
years so here's the problem
the trophy can be replaced by the laptop
by the ball
by uh by my camera the camera did not
fit in and the suitcase can be replaced
by the closet by the drawer by the trunk
anything that i can put stuff in yeah so
this is a template and and you can
change
did not with dipped and you can change
although
by because and because by sense
so the combinations i can i can give you
uh
in one second i can give you a
reasonable argument that says this
sentence
is a template for 200 million sentences
yeah but the thing is this is this is
obvious to us because we've been
speaking about the curse of
dimensionality and that is all about how
when you have increasing dimensions and
statistics the volume of the space
increases exponentially which means
actually um you have a specificity but
you have no approximation uh boundary
right so you lose generalization it's
exactly the same here so you know you
were talking about the difference
between big and small
that's the wrong way to think about it
actually we have specificity we have too
much specificity
we actually have a an exponentially
large number of templates but will never
have statistical significance on any
representation of those templates
because it's in a vast space well every
template has has a combinatorial number
of instantiations of it
yeah so it's the cursive templates
rather than the cursive dimensionality
i was going to say it's not
dimensionality it's the it's the it's
the
what is it called technically
productivity productivity as in
production production rules yeah yeah
production and logical sense like
production in a logical sense or in a in
a yeah in a formal automata sense the
productivity of even a simple template
like the one i just described and this
is a simple sentence guys the the
productivity is i can show you the
numbers we're talking about 200 million
sentences a child can make from this
template alone so yes you can learn it
from from observation but how many
things i have to see not fit in things
remember i'm talking about learning from
actual instances
like
other otherwise otherwise we're doing
hand waving people say oh but then i can
put this bar and say no no learning from
instances
is brutal guys so when you want to
defend it you have to tell me how uh
hold hold on
you have to tell me look learning from
data either you adopted and defended or
you don't there's not a middle right if
you want to defend learning from
observations a template like this you
have to convince me how a child
learns 200 million sentences from few
examples if you don't have an
explanation for that
the rest is hand waving the rest is um
yeah can i put it back to you though
because how is it possible
to learn from high dimensional data
it's not it's it's theoretically
impossible but it works for a reason and
it works because the entire endeavor of
machine learning is about essentially
finding structure and reducing
effectively reducing the dimensionality
of data so why can't a similar approach
be applied to natural language
understanding okay but wait wait i want
to bring up something that uh
said which is yes and i think he's right
about this tim
you know people often say something like
ml works i think we have to take that
with a grain of salt so it works today
because of immense amounts of human
engineering that went into creating
specific neural network architectures
that happen to work and nobody talks
about the 69 different architectures
that they tried that failed they only
bring the one that worked you know plan
nine the one that worked they bring like
here's the horseshoe network you know
which is like awesome because it's just
the first one we thought of you know the
fact is there was tremendous there was a
tremendous amount of human intuition
that went into building
networks that encode structurally prior
knowledge that's why they work prior
knowledge that that's a big part of it
because we're the this
this pruning of all the
or the massive infinite possibilities
where you're playing from data if you
blindly play with data and go up good
luck yeah yeah but but it's more than
it's more than what keith said it's when
we say it's working where
well i mean it's almost working first of
all let
let's qualify working it's almost barely
working and in very tiny tiny
i mean
it's clearly working in vision so on
very
on
very highly dimensional data sets with
thousands tens of thousands of
dimensions it's working brilliantly
right i agree with you it's not working
at all in language understanding and
that doesn't rule out that some trick
might make it work better in the future
so i disagree with some similar tricks
tim here's my challenge okay for
somebody to claim that machine learning
pure machine learning without human
interference is quote working for
anything
this is my challenge you start
with a fully connected neural network
bank fully connected neural network
blank slate do i don't care if you do
random initialization you can do all
that crap if you want to but start with
a fully connected network and then train
it to do something let me see you do
that so you start with a fully connected
neural network i'll even let you tweak
you know width and height that's fine
you start with that and show that it can
do image recognition and then i will
believe that machine learning works yeah
so no no one is disagreeing with you on
that keith so the the reason it works is
we've created inductive priors that
essentially the only purpose of these
prizes to uh reduce the dimensionality
of the lens circumscribe the problem
yeah exactly
and it works then this is like one of
wally's binding problems it's not
machine learning it's it's human
augmented machine learning works
oh yeah but that's a distinction that i
thought went without saying so okay
i agree with you okay yep right but but
going back to tim's question
it's not working perfectly in image
recognition after all the caveats we
said second second holder i mean we seem
to forget adversarial problems i can
fool a network with one pixel i mean
let's let's define working let's define
working tim i mean and there's a reason
for that it's again it's again the
problem of the paradigm itself i can
optimize
uh with uh
look when you optimize going up and with
back prop
i can reverse this problem there's two
basically there are three variables
and uh one unknown in the learning
process right
in the learning process i have a i know
the label
and i know the object
right and i'm trying to discover the
weights that's essentially it right
in
an adversarial attacks
i know the weights and i know the label
i have to give you x again three
variables two knowns i can always do it
in other words technically speaking i
can always
compute a function that produces an
output that you think
was the result of x but actually i
pushed z
adversarial attacks can always happen
always in this paradigm okay it's simple
i like you optimizing learning
i optimize to find the input that will
fool you to produce y as a label
done okay the mathematics show that it
can always be done but besides that
that's i'll say image recognition
is a decent application of machine
learning and they did okay
yeah on the adversarial examples i i
don't see that as being a particularly
salient point i think given what we know
about this spline interpretation of
neural networks it should be obvious
that that happens
there may well be similar adversarial
attacks on symbolic systems
um well there are
even adversarial attacks on human beings
i mean that's that's the name of the
game for you know magic for illusion
artists right is it's they create
quote smoke and mirrors that can fool a
person i think what's interesting about
the adversarial examples though
is that
human thought processes human cognition
is fooled in very different ways than
machine learning is fooled like i you
know if you give me a fuzzy hot dog like
even if it's some rainbow matrix that
you put on top of it like i know it's
still a hot dog whereas machine learning
like wally said gets tricked by some one
little rainbow pixel somewhere that
makes it think it and so and and i think
and in my opinion and look people have
different explanations for what that
means but in my opinion that hints at
people do this kind of higher level
larger scale kind of reasoning
right exactly rather than this very
micro detailed texture based kind of
look up that's right but that's right
because to to say it slightly
differently i agree with you keith the
this comes down to approximation theory
and neural networks work in the pixel
space alone
right and they learn these polyhedra and
the the positioning and and pose of
these polyhedra is just a function of
the training data that they've seen
human beings perform abstract reasoning
we are traversing concept space which is
an entirely different space yeah agreed
but yeah the pro this is okay that's
another way probably it's another way of
saying
the look in in a neural network the
information is distributed there's no
there's no structural information like
nowhere in your neural network are you
going to see
whiskers of a cat
okay so that that
and it's related to the paradigm itself
and again we go back to symbolic and
structural and discrete information
if if
we we know it's a cat even though 90 of
it is hidden right because i saw
whiskers of a cat
right
in in a neural network
nowhere you have whiskers of a cat you
have
this weird i actually if you if you look
deep on on the stuff that's inside
nowhere you're gonna see anything that
on its own will tell you it's a cat
we don't reason like this we reason
it's a cat if it has this and this and
this but
without getting too much into and for
folks that want to do kind of what walid
is talking about there's the it's the
open ai microscope right
it kind of lets you look at
you know saliency maps or visualizations
of the different latent layers is that
right tim that's it but i don't think
that's helpful in this situation because
the the open ai microscope that solves
an optimization problem to find an input
that maximally activates let's say a
layer in a neural network or a logic or
something like that but what waleed is
saying is that when you think about
these um abstract categories
a logician would go top down but the way
a neural network works as we just
described in our previous episode is an
input example of a cat comes in and then
all the various different features on
that will be projected into different um
parts of the latent space right right
and then somewhere down the line there's
some kind of um soft max which is saying
are the whisk is there is is the cat no
it's very bottom up and there'll be some
kind of threshold right and then we'll
generate the softmax and it will say
cats that's a completely different form
of reasoning
completely actually it's turned upside
down and then no wonder we have bottom
up top down it's a top down will say
okay i i wouldn't apply it to image
recognition okay
for for many reasons but i would say if
it had if you can find this part and
this part forget everything else it must
be a cat like
there are salient features that tell me
this is a horse forget the rest i don't
care now that's a top down approach it's
a horse if it has this and this and it
has this if i can find okay that's a
duck it's difficult to do image
recognition top down obviously we tried
for 40 years
it used to be called computer vision
they didn't succeed it's very difficult
and it turned out that this type of
problem bottom up
does quite a
good job i mean man i mean with all the
the
the limitations we've been discussing no
one came close to i mean now some some
computer vision uh
image recognition systems are
mind-boggling they they capture exactly
what's happening okay that's good
language is different and well just with
some caveats so i think people don't
realize the reason some of these vision
models work well is because they are
trained to do a very specific task
they're either doing image
classification or object detection or
segmentation and they've been trained
for a specific number of classes so they
are specifically trained to look for
cats
and at some point if you increase the
number of classes that it's looking for
it will get worse because there's always
a trade-off right right so what happens
when you have different types of cats
it's now not going to work very well is
it that's why that's why i keep saying
it works but you know as a practitioner
i have a lot of problems with that
because
i mean it works with so many
qualifications right because when you
when you actually go and try and deploy
and use you know
vision models man it's a nightmare to
actually get them to actually do
you know real world practical problems
but but keith it does a lot better than
any other paradigm has managed to do i i
i have to admit i mean
try to do symbolic
image recognition good luck i mean it's
like right so i have to admit that what
are you comparing it this paradigm of
going bottom up from raw signals
has proved to be more efficient than
top-down symbolic approaches exactly but
as long as we caveat it it's a paradigm
of trade-offs engineering trade-offs
just as max welling was saying to us
there's the um the bias variance
trade-off how much do you leave to the
data how much bias you put in there
sometimes having too much bias can hurt
you sometimes
working better in extrapolation makes it
work worse for interpolation
just the specificity of the task that
every single network is trained on all
of these things are engineering
trade-offs
right right
no i agree i agree but i i have to also
give uh
i mean you
you can't
you just can't uh refute science i mean
top-down image recognition problems
where it's essentially pattern
recognition problems top-down discrete
methods have failed miserably right okay
so i
uh and i don't think that's the right
paradigm for those right so but the
issue is not that to me you know it's
still in the big picture of an in the
larger scheme of things when we discuss
deep learning or machine learning my
issue is not everything is learnable in
the first place so you like even if you
get to the point where you have perfect
machine learning
machinery technology
whatever you want to call it all
all that's underneath machine learning
even at large
even if that technology becomes perfect
you're never gonna learn most of the
relevant knowledge that makes us human
because that knowledge is not learnable
from data
so i i have a bigger question
regardless of how accurate machine
learning or good
or bad all the good abandoning ugly and
deep learning there are
most of what matters to us
that allows us to function the way we
function is not learnable stuff it's
stuff that is either discovered
or deduced
or we are told about it by those that
discovered it or deduced it and i can
give you an infinite number of examples
where
to learn that stuff
you would need and theoretically
that means scientifically and
mathematical you would need an infinite
number of examples forget it
okay but otherwise if you don't want to
do science then
you know that's fine but if you want to
do science an infinite number of
examples means no
because we don't have an infinite number
of examples and we don't have an
infinite number of years to learn
something okay
there are folks out there that say
um it's absolutely fine that neural
networks are like hash tables and the
human brain is like a hash table and
because what you're saying is that in
order to
approximate
let's say some kind of mathematical
function to extract
or oracle i don't want to complicate
things or or a common sense fact like
transitivity
you know people always take me people
always take me to logic and mathematics
no no no it's about a child learning how
to how to walk around it's much simpler
than that even those cannot be learned
from data but we are talking about
extrapolation so you're saying if you if
you have the template and you have the
abstract rule you can extrapolate into
any situation we were talking about this
on the show if you have y equals x
squared
you can extrapolate even outside of the
training range into any new situation
and you're saying it in language these
abstract templates can produce
exponentially
many data examples so it doesn't it
doesn't actually actually technically
speaking an infant right but
that's right so it it it seems like a
pointless thing to say that you could
equate understanding to having the
magical infinite hash table of the
universe because that doesn't exist it's
a little bit like saying neural networks
are turing complete or neural networks
are universal function approximators
these are appeals to infinity we don't
live in a world where you could have
this infinite sampling of reality we
need to have abstract extrapolation
exactly and and and tim we we keep
forgetting we don't have i mean
it's like everything in computation
everything is is time and space storage
and time we also don't have an infinite
amount of years i can i cannot spend 10
years to learn transitivity
and another 25 years to learn the
contained and common sense logic
template and so i i would have to live a
million years to know how to walk
outside the room that
there's also something called effective
computability not just computability
even if theoretically you can this is
not how we work now people argue and and
i
i say that
probably that's the most serious answer
i've received
is that yes we have built these things
using after
thousands hundreds of thousands of years
of evolution
and they're going to say
we're trying to simulate those
years of evolution in machine learning
so give us some time
but but that that's that's a bogus
argument because when when you're
talking about things that cannot be
learned differently this is not about
evolution we're not allowed to learn the
stuff not only we cannot and we don't
have enough time
learning the the the ml paradigm that we
have now unless we we come up with a
different learning uh paradigm there are
probably i can envision learning
paradigm
sometime in the future that are not
exactly all
bottom up from data
who says that's the only learning
paradigm
but this paradigm as it exists now
does not explain how
in
a couple of years a child learns
a huge number of high-level templates
pretty much like his neighbor child
learned them although they both have
completely different individual
experiences yeah there is no magic here
there's no magic
the contained end relationship the
transitive relationship blah blah blah
these are not subject to individual
experiences
this is not something i learned
from my sensory input and how i
experience the environment and reward
what is the reward
in transitivity
there's a lot that we know that has
nothing to do with extrapolating from
data end of story i'm talking about the
paradigm at large
even computationally even
computationally whether it's in language
or in high-level reasoning
uh and i'm not talking about formal
reasoning common sense recently yeah and
i want to make a comment too on the on
the infinity point that tim brought up
which is that
you know the the infinity that that kind
of sits
in say the turing machine model or any
computational model
are potential infinities so the idea is
you have an algorithm and
it has a potentially infinite tape okay
what that means practically is that you
can run the algorithm and if you run out
of memory you save at state you go and
you upgrade your memory you double your
memory and then you keep computing from
then on okay you're right it's a
theoretical for
a neural network it's a different it's
an actual infinity like you have to have
a circuit
okay that's literally already splayed
out actually infinite at training time
when you do the training because it's
creating very different if you want to
call it an algorithm like the
calculation that a neural network
performs at the end of the day every
single one of them is equivalent to an
unrolled
feed-forward single pass
network okay no matter how much it's
obscured by it's an rnn or an lstm or
whatever it has this equivalence is this
unrolled network
yeah and and you mentioned that point
with the [ __ ] the other day and i think
he missed
the memory in a neural network is
different from the memory in a symbolic
system the memory in the symbolic system
i can always increase my memory outside
of the logic exactly
i can i can always add they're not
confused
the theoretical model is completely
different that's right the memory in a
neural network is built in the
architecture that's right it's
you cannot increase the memory without
changing your your depaul your your
architecture precisely in a symbolic
system i can always add more memory and
not change a single line of logic yeah
and this and this has like practical
consequences this has very it's that's a
very important point that's what
companies and it has practical
consequences which is that the the
calculations the functions that you end
up with when you search the logic search
the space and then in are very different
functions than the functions that we
encode as algorithms as as programs okay
and and this is the crux of why we find
that there are very different kind of
domains in these
in which these different paradigms
perform well or they perform very
differently
in different domains that's the whole
point behind pi i can write a tiny
little
logic okay that can compute or addition
or addition compute the nth digit of pi
with an expandable memory but it will
terminate in a finite amount of time use
a finite amount of memory and give you
give you the answer there's no finite
neural network that you can train
that will compute the nth digit of pi
can i may i say that we've discussed
this i know um
many times before and and it seems like
we're pointing out the obvious right the
whole argument here is that's why some
people
they keep bringing the point of
an exponentially large
lookup table the reason they do that is
they have to have this almost infinite
neural network to explain things yeah
so the argument here is not that simple
they that
they know technically that's the only
way out is to have an almost infinite
neural network i know but the thing is
infinite neural networks don't exist and
as keith was saying neural networks have
a finite representational power so i
think we should park that but it's a
little bit like talking about you know
touring completeness and and universal
function
it's it's the road to nowhere from a
discussion point of view so what i want
to do is is move to a devil's advocate
so if i was a neural network um advocate
i would be making a slightly different
argument right so let's say i've been
i've been god for a bit but well
let's say i've been studying computer
science and i've been studying about
things like algorithms and dynamic
programming and whatnot and what you're
basically saying is that this is a
combinatorics problem right so um what
happens if i swap this word in what
happens if i swap that word in well it's
like the um the search space blows up
but if i was a neural network advocate i
would be making the argument well when i
when i see that word replaced why don't
i um just blow up the search space and
then retrain my neural network just kind
of fanning out that part of the search
base and do that like lazily evaluated
why wouldn't i do that where's the data
you're going to train on no i would have
to say i would have some symbolic
templates so it'd be a hybrid model so i
would know that bag is a type of this
thing and then i would blow up some data
and retrain myself incrementally prior
knowledge
structural knowledge okay so
okay
so you're gonna incorporate a type
hierarchy you're gonna incorporate logic
into it uh and you're gonna
do so
okay so
okay then then how else would you do
that and then end of discussion
that's the whole point but that would be
a huge
point yeah but let me take your point
seriously okay is
is
yeah most likely as a student you would
immediately reach towards
familiar kind of
symbolic logic
you know programming type tools to
augment to augment your just a second
let me finish to augment your neural
network because you realize very quickly
as a human being with your feeble
cognition as feeble as it is you realize
very quickly that just this neural
network with with data
is the road to nowhere and so you're
going to augment it with all the
symbolic like kind of stuff okay now so
look
computer science is all about finding
the right abstraction that's what you
know the guy who invented c plus plus
who said that on the lex friedman um
show right you find the right
abstraction okay but but here's the
problem okay and i agree with you like
that's the way a practical person would
do it here's the problem is that
that's still limited by human beings
capability to perform that you know
intuitive logical symbolic you know kind
of reasoning to come up with the
abstractions etc and the holy the holy
grail is
can we get a machine to do that like we
really want a machine to go out well
hold on we really would love it if we
could just i don't know feed a bunch of
you know
metrics from the solar system and and
experiments on earth and nickel some
morally and whatever else and have it go
aha i have discovered general relativity
for you here's the set of symbolic
equations that describe you know the
system you've given me like that's what
we want to be able to do
the problem is neural networks are not
going to get us there okay they're just
the current paradigm of neural networks
are not going to get us there and we
really would like people to take that
fact seriously to devote more effort
into
whatever that future system is
hybrid systems neural networks with
symbolic layers integrated i don't know
differentiable neural computers who
knows
i have another twist on tim's uh
suggestion
uh
if if you're gonna augment a neural
network with these symbolic structures
so obviously one of them is gonna be a
type hierarchy where a briefcase in a
suitcase and a bag they're all
containers of sorts you have to have
that right otherwise
we're back to the combinatorics okay and
you're going to have to have a laptop
and a ball and a trophy or like artifact
right and you're gonna have to have a
rule like we started with if x is bigger
than y then x will not fit in y blah
blah blah okay so basically
okay then
you're using a neural network i'm
assuming still you insist on using it
since all of that knowledge now is
already structured
you're using an ordinance i'm assuming
for its learning capability
well either
it's learning or
it's compositional ability
uh
we can put the second one into a
discussion because i'm not sure what you
mean exactly by that but well just for
for example you you don't you don't need
to write a parser you don't need to know
really anything at all you can just no
no you load a sentence into a vector and
you can no no you still you still do
because you you want to know what
augments what and what what goes where
you still do but
let's not get into the technical detail
to me and i think you both agree the
strongest point of neural networks is
the learnability as a matter of fact if
that wasn't the
thing that is different from symbolic
systems it would never have come to this
place differentiable learnability is the
yes yeah that is the part that's partly
my point you don't need to know any
technical knowledge about language all
you need to do is train a transformer
model on some
on some data from wikipedia and it will
just auto-magically represent
you're saying then i misunderstood
you're saying
your training data
is expanded massively using
the type hierarchy and so basically
you're creating instead of a single
example you're blowing it up into 200
million examples by instantiating it
with different
but doing it lazily
so when when you see um something come
up yeah
it's a little bit like um you know
search engines they they take words and
they they do seriously
okay so the augmentation is on the data
you're simulating an infinite number of
examples a child might see
in your data
and then not
on on demand so when when a query comes
in okay that's a technical i can i can
take some words i can use my but the
question then is should the type
hierarchy be human designed or could we
search for it
the human hierarchy is not uh
an issue because i don't want to get
into the ontology
because in in my mind
the nature of things is well defined and
it's not up to us and a tree is a tree
and a tree is a living thing and unless
someone
and i'll talk a real ontology that's
underneath language if anyone questions
it we have a label for them we say
they're mentally challenged right if
someone says a tree is not a living
thing you could always say that but okay
let's put the
ontological categories not everything in
nature but the basic ontological
categories that a child is aware of when
they're three or four
i i'm still baffled by if the
learnability is the biggest thing
right
then
why why a neural network i can do
inductive logic programming which learns
from these templates
and actually learns very effectively
then why a neural network
what i'm baffled by is okay it fails to
do this and it fails to do that but
let's keep the neural network what is it
what what is it that
is i mean
is it just because we have neurons in
the brain and we think somehow by
calling something neural uh we're gonna
find something magical
i am really baffled what
you know inductive logic programming is
so powerful if if people if it was given
enough that genetic algorithms can learn
i mean why is it we insist
that let's do all these fixes outside
and keep the neural network
it's brittleness that that should be
clear so so the knowledge acquisition
bottleneck and the brittleness of the
knowledge representation meaning that
every system that got designed all of
the common sense knowledge would have to
be recaptured again from scratch that's
the only reason why neural networks are
being used today
it's it's the ability for you to train a
neural network once and use it in a
variety of downstream applications but
we just but we just agreed
that it was not
on its own
it wasn't working
well it wasn't even trained once it was
trained on demand by a you know symbolic
data generation
process right so we're back to we're
back to square mall
sure but one thing that we were saying
just before the conversation started was
we are now seeing folks use hybrid
systems to extend these models right
like deepmind they they've done this
information retrieval system where you
put a query in and it will go to google
a bunch of times and it will stitch this
prompt together and then stick it into
gbt3 so wally do you thought that was
actually almost um them admitting defeat
to a certain extent oh yeah there they
were saying that we can't keep
increasing this indefinitely i mean even
i if i have trillions of trillions of
parameters actually they showed that the
improvement in performance was
negligible can you can you link and link
that article for me i'm gonna take a
look at that
yeah there's a couple of things actually
they're on the deep mind side uh i think
one of them
basically they proved and they stated
explicitly that
whether it's trillions or one billion
it's almost the same
and uh so anyway some of us knew that
but hey now it's proven by
machine learning people themselves
but they're they're actually now saying
we need an infinite amount of data
i kept talking about infinity that these
guys are trying to chase infinity and
now they are admitting in a paper yes it
looks like we have to chase and finish
like
how much data do you need
it's like the category theory folks you
know it's like you have uh you know
uh arrows pointing to other arrows
pointing to groups there well hey if we
just go to infinity then we'll then
we'll have to not worry about this
increasing hierarchy anymore
yeah i get the feeling category theory
is also too abstract to be
there's a big difference between a
potential infiniti and an actual
infiniti it's it's like if i'm trying to
play the latest version of
you know quake or doom or what
whatever's the latest greatest from id
and my computer doesn't have enough
memory and it's kind of choppy it's
really easy for me to go get another
memory stick
and plug it in i don't have to recode
the software like to take advantage of
that i don't have to retrain the game
like in order to play actually infinity
is really at the heart of this remember
the guy guys the paper that uh actually
proved uh
uh on the side it proved the equivalent
spin compression and learnability but
but the point of the paper was
they used uh cantor's results and and
goodell's the results that
uh basically infinities are not all
equal you know the argument and said
theory that okay the set of integers is
infinite yeah the set of reals is
infinite but obviously one infinity is
larger than the values of zero alpha one
et cetera out aleph one out of that so
there are infinities and then
and goodell you tried to see if you can
prove
because this is
uh
this is not proven believe it or not
that that there are infinities that are
different in size
and goodell proved that you cannot prove
this it's an open question but
intuitively yeah it makes sense that the
real infinite is bigger than the integer
infinite but besides that point those
guys use this result to prove that
learnability can be undecidable now
here's here's what the
real result is
in doing that they prove compressibility
and learnability are equivalent but i i
quote that for other reasons for
language but
there's a bigger uh
result in
or or there's a more important
implication in the result
basically there are tractable infinities
and intractable infinite language is an
infinite thing but it's very tractable i
i don't know what makes it and that's
i'm looking into that now i don't know
what makes but it's related to top down
and bottom up so for example
in in doing image recognition by a
symbolic approach discrete approach
you're going into an intractable
infinity the number of features and
rules you would have to put
is probably intractable
bottom up here you're doing you're also
playing with infinity but it's
attractable infinite
there are problems the other way around
so let's take
i want to define tractorpool
uh tractable is because you can deal
with infinite domains and and get a
result i mean uh we do it all the time
uh any any mathematical function is
infinite it's an infinite hash table you
just said a second ago that vision was
different to language because it was
intractable so exactly how is vision
different to language i'm thinking out
loud now as we speak this is the latest
thing that is is on my mind and it's
related to top-down problem solving
versus bottom-up there are problems that
they are naturally
bottom-up images image recognition is
one of them
uh if you take things like discovering a
sorting algorithm it just cannot happen
bottom up because
let's imagine i want to
i want i i didn't know of uh quicksort
or merson i didn't know of it we're
still in the 40s right
and uh i want to come up with it let's
think about it bottom up
how would you start saying
if you try this with this and try this
with it you're dealing with infinite and
i'll show you top down you're dealing
with infinite but it's attractable
infinity it is naturally a top-down
uh kind of problem bottom up you will
never assemble things
in certain ways that will allow you to
come up with merge sword forget it
top down
it's easy okay if i replace this by this
let's try this replace this statement
with an equivalent statement so top down
i can deduce a new sorting algorithm
what i'm saying is there are problems
that are naturally solvable top down
more than others
and and we've learned that in in at
least in problem-solving courses logic
and
there are problems on the other hand
that are more naturally solvable
bottom-up
in both cases you're an infant domain
but to reach a tractable solution in
that infinite domain bottom up is better
than top down
let's linger on top down for a second
because this is very similar to the work
from um josh tannenbaum doing the um the
inductive program
search
so that is also an exponential problem
because we're always dealing with
exponential blow-ups whether it's the
cursive dimensionality whether it's the
templates whether it's the the
combinatorics of the search space so if
you go top down you have a combinatorial
problem right but i know that josh
tannenbaum has i think with dreamcoder
discovered um sorting algorithms
presumably ones which are similar to
quicksort
so what's the problem here is it is it
because there's a verification problem
and after it discovered it you wouldn't
be able to reason about its behavior
what's the limiting factor here
so
i'll tell you about sorting for example
and and
top-down approaches require symbolic
knowledge
so if i'm going from
uh
i i can show you how you from insertion
sword which is the most intuitive way of
sorting
right
basically you're saying
if i have more than one object
assume the rest is sorted then all i
have to do is insert this in the right
place and the whole thing will be sorted
so the most intuitive way of sorting is
insertion sort i can show you starting
from insertion sword and going through
some transformations which could be
infinite because you can always come
back and go right it's an infinite space
of possibilities where can i go from a
certain function by doing
semantically preserving transformations
let's call them
uh i can show you with four or five
transformations you get merge sort which
is the optimal sorting from the most
inefficient
okay this can be easily done top down
because i'm using symbolic logic i'm
using symbolic knowledge that this
statement is equivalent to this that i
can replace this by this so for example
i can replace
uh x attached to a list by x in a list
appended to that list they're equivalent
so i can use basically equivalences i
can use arithmetic transformations that
i know they're meaning preserving long
story short top down with few
transformations because i'm guided by
where i'm going in my search space i
know where i'm going
and i can i can do this bottom up you
know what you would have to do in this
problem
you would have to add to
patch together every combination of
things that you can have
to come up with something
it's it's almost
it probably can be done but it probably
would need
i can't even imagine how many steps it
will take to come up with something that
bottom up right
theory theorem
if i start with a working program
and all i did are meaning preserving
transformations then whatever i get is a
working program
okay so let's put that i don't need to
execute it but how do i know it's an
optimal one or how do i know that's a
different problem how do i know it has
better complexity
when you say meaning preserving do you
mean it does the same thing it's about
semantics
a program semantically is a hash table
input output
it's an infinite hash table
any list you give me the output of the
sorted list
in this case right
okay so any program
the semantics of any program is an
infinite hash table
from input to output
by the way this is basic computation any
program on earth
is an infinite hash table for these
inputs i give you these outputs and it
never ends for all
for all xyz i give you r
right okay
meaning preserving means these two
programs no matter how you write them
will produce the same
table extension
their intention is different
extension what they produce is the same
but a quick sort might have a different
intention yes intention i don't care
my whole point is to do intentional
transformations
to get to get at a prop another property
of the program
right which is it's it's time complexity
probably i don't care about the space
complex
but one property of the program as we
know is the extension the function i
have to preserve the function because my
end goal is to have the same semantic
function in the end
right
sure and i want to play with the
intention
to produce another program that gives me
a better attribute somewhere else which
is time complex sure but isn't there
uncountably infinite many intentions
that could produce an n log n right
right you can always say i have a better
complexity analytically
that this performance is better than
this i know that did i reach the optimal
that's an open question we don't know if
we can beat n log in you know you can
you can statistically measure um
time complexity by running the algorithm
so like you did on it on one input so
you give it an input you see how how
many cycles it takes
crudely yes and they do this in
numerical analysis yeah so you can do it
you can get an approximation first time
we do that kind of thing all the time
actually like that's a pretty common
you know computer science activity if
you can't if you can't prove it um and
then there are cases where algorithms
you know or where are problems have
theoretically proven you know upper and
lower bounds
on complexity like you can't possibly do
better than this complexity better than
that and you know and if you're doing
any worse than this one you're you're
like you know if you add parallel
programming into the picture analyzing
like search becomes constant like if i
have if i have a list of 100 elements
and i have 100 processes yeah it's
logged in well it can't be constant
because you have to wait for all the
results and and and combine them itself
yeah and that's that's a whole you know
area of study as well is like how
parallelizable are
our problems what's the speed there's a
limit to parallelization et cetera so i
did just want to say you know um
uh
there are practical means by in in this
pro number one it's task specific like
we keep running into this over and over
again which is that some tasks are you
know
have provable aspects some don't you
know you can do empirical measurements
but if you're talking about the general
problem like just the general problem of
give me you know so like chalet's kind
of conception of things like i have this
general intelligence which you give it a
task and kind of an oracle and then it
derives
algorithms you know to to do to solve
that particular pat task that's the
general ai you know for that general
task i think this is a lot of what tim
like this is a lot of what waleed is
talking about which is kind of these
general limitations on on like a
an algorithm that finds algorithms or
you know things like that and you know
that's where
and that's obviously what we want
some general ai to do so like kind of
the like the
you mentioned dream coder you know
exactly what the dream coder kind of
abstract talks about right which is
look the the ideal is that we have
programs that write other programs and
they do so in a way that's kind of
modular and they reuse components and
and therefore they're much more
efficient than just exploring this
combinatorial space of like
all possible programs
and just one really quick point here
just for our our listeners i want to
point out
um a couple things which is one the
space of all computer programs is
countably infinite
um and in fact that was important and
you know girdles proof of of
incompleteness because he developed this
mapping between
you know the real or uh natural numbers
and computer programs and and was able
to show that there are statements that
are true that you know can't be proven
and then i wanted to come back to one
thing wally which is what were you
saying was still an open question in
terms of
sort of sizes infinity because the only
one i'm aware of right now is just that
you know
if you have al of zero which is like the
infinity of natural numbers
and aleph one which is the infinity of
the power set of natural numbers so it's
like the next most provably
larger you know class of infinity
there's an open question as to whether
there's anything in between and so like
the famous one is the continuum
hypothesis which says that
that the complexities this is what i was
saying this is what i was trying to call
the continuum hypothesis which which
goodell said
will will never be
we will never know if it's true
in other words saying that the continuum
hypothesis is itself a girdle statement
it is an unprovable okay either way and
they use that they use that to say
this translates to in machine learning
to
some problems that will hit
the false because the continuum have
both could be true or false
and they proved in that paper that there
are some machine learning
problems there are some problems where
machine learning
is intractable for
while some it's quite good which sort of
summarizes what we've been talking about
what is learnable first of all and what
is effectively learnable and so they're
their proof was hey machine learning is
not the end of all and it's not the only
game in town there are problems where
machine learning is not the right tool
the reason i bring that cycle is i can't
believe you said that
wally okay okay i'm i'm gonna well i'm
now living in dc yeah the bay area was
was a dangerous place to say that dc is
safer okay
safer let's put it that
way
and so that's what brought us to okay
take something like
sorting and improving a bad sorting
algorithm into that's a top-down problem
and it's manageable
because i know uh how to do meaning
preserving transformations top down i
have the rules but that requires
symbolic manipulation there's no other
way doing it bottom up i can't even
begin to start thinking how it you would
do that and
and i i can imagine many other problems
like that on the other hand i mentioned
that
pattern recognition types of problems
like image recognition i can't even
start thinking how you would do it top
down symbolically so that paper
it opened my eyes like wait a minute
there are there is a good it's like
there's a good infinity and a bad
infinity and there's a
and it's related to top down versus
bottom up just because you can't think
about how you could do image recognition
doesn't necessarily mean that you can't
do it yeah of course not of course i
don't send ten commandments here no no
i'm just saying no i can't
i'm i'm interested in in this continuum
of human design because uh
you're a huge advocate of of humans
being able to design
knowledge and ai architectures right i i
i have a suspicion that a working agi
architecture might be an emergent
property of some low-level system or it
might be something which is just beyond
our comprehension i i agree with you
that there's no there's gonna be an
emergency if you you don't have agi if
you cannot somehow simulate emergence
definitely but from zero no
from blank slate no look everything even
geometry has to sit on some axioms i
mean the uh it call them the
the axioms of nature right i don't know
but there's no way we're starting blank
because the number of the degrees of
freedom are
i mean where do you go you have to have
some axioms they call them in in some
ai
corners they call them common sense
naive physics they call them common
sense psychology they call them
it's the common sense of how the word
functions at a pretty
basic level you have to start from
somewhere so that's my only
you you do
but it's quite interesting that i mean
in the machine learning world the reason
it works is maybe the the physical rules
that govern our universe only produce
very few factors of variation which
means the curse of dimensionality might
not be such a huge big deal and i think
similarly you could apply the same
rationale to um certain types of
abstract category and certain types of
i mean you know mathematics for example
in some sense it's actually much simpler
than we realize which means any agi
emerging property could have um emerged
from few abstract categories not the
uncountably many that i suspect
right two things on that that's a good
point
the uncountably the the few
could be
a lot more than you might think
that what what you're saying we're we're
gonna end up with a few that few
is a huge few okay that one that's one
point which is unmanageable i mean i can
think of problems we just talked about
sword imagine imagine starting bottom up
from
that view is not that innocent like few
would would entail there are some
combinations that we don't look at at
all because they're not part of the
nature
these combinations just don't exist so
the only combinations that can make
sense are the ones that we're going to
look at
this is in the physical world it's true
but in the abstract world i can imagine
unthinkable concepts that can't
physically happen but it's not about
what you can imagine it's about the
intrinsic complexity or structure so
i'm making the case that physical
reality is actually much simpler than we
realize it's generated by simple
physical rules and also the same thing
works in concept space i'm making the
argument that if you abstract enough
there are very few relatively speaking
abstract templates that we need to
describe the world that we live in like
the transitive template
right uh okay that's a nice project uh
what are
just to size it up like are we are we
talking uh the order of
a million ten millions hundred million
that's a good point uh what are these
uh what are these abstract templates
out of which
we instantiate everything we see and we
we observe an uh
interesting question i don't know
everything that we experience in our
physical reality
should be describable by abstract
templates which could extrapolate into
any situation in experience which which
i believe by which i believe by the way
i know and and then
but that includes events not imagine i
mean the other day i was i was going
back to dig into the semantics of events
events have their own logic and and they
events contain other events so so a big
event contains sub events and events uh
might overlap and then one might proceed
the other exactly i mean there's a whole
logic for events
and it's a clear logic that cannot be
disputed it's not up to us right events
have a
starting point and an end point to have
a duration so there's a there's a neat
logic for it's called the logic of
events
i don't know how many templates you can
generate there and we take now for
granted we
we function in the word based on them we
don't know we're following these
templates of event logic i mean there's
a logic behind events when when you are
told this thing is happening now you can
immediately trigger so many templates
that you know
so
it's i don't know it's a big question
how many of those we have i have no idea
it's uh and you're saying that that's
just the the logic of the universe so in
the universe there is a logic of events
and we acquired that logic
and at least in the universe we live in
it seems like you can't beat any of
these templates you can't you can't you
can't refute it and and there's no way
this can be
grasped from experience i mean it's it's
beyond us
to say that
i mean if you look at the logic of
events
the reason i mention that is i'm always
mentioning transitivity because it's
something simple people relate to but
there are many others
it's called naive physics how the world
works i mean it's
at least the universe we're aware of and
you can't beat them you can't beat any
of these rules it's not up to us that's
how the world functions
actually which brings me to another
point we give each
we give ourselves too much credit humans
we think we're inventing when we we
invent very little
we are we are we are we are barely
discovering what's out there so we give
like we think the world will not run
without us it's the other way around the
world runs in spite of us we're just
trying to discover
we're just trying to discover those
metaphysical realities that most of them
are not learned they are there and we
stumble upon them and we discover them
so hang on are you saying the logic of
events is a bit like a meme
and it's not that i did somehow i
acquire it i wasn't born with it because
it's a meme that floats around and then
i'm i'm
through instruction i'm taught how the
logic of events works
i i i believe more than that i believe
these templates are part of our genetic
and
we
they how they got imprinted and how when
did they when did we acquire them big
question i have no idea
but i think they're instantiated and
immediately we pick them up we say ah
this is that that's it all i need to do
is see one example and and all of a
sudden that template becomes
instantiated it's like initially it was
like in a wrapped in a box never used
and
when when i see one example of it and
now it becomes active and i have proof
that it works i saw actually an instance
where it was instantiated perfectly and
it works so now it becomes not just a
nice wrapped
template that i never used i've used it
and i and i know it and and and most of
these don't ask me how many are there
are uh
are like that because i can't there's
i can't think of any other plausible
explanation i mean to tell me that i've
seen
uh
i've seen a couple of events and they
work this way first of all there's so
many
and second of all i and you cannot see
them differently
these templates work we
they work in spite of us like plato said
they work even if the universe didn't
exist well hold on a minute just before
we get to that point because that that
mud is the waters a little bit but but
you're saying that all of these
templates like the logic of events
they're they are a projection of
physical reality and then
we essentially kind of um inherit them
eventually in our dna code and the
efficiency of information transfer
between physical reality and our dna
code is something that we can be
discussed so as you just said we haven't
discovered all of the templates yet
there are still many more projected by
physical reality that we haven't
discovered yet because we never had the
opportunity to instantiate them so there
might be so many still wrapped up
never used yes but this gets to the main
point which is that the templates are an
emergent phenomenon of physical reality
so you could try and model the templates
or you could go a level deeper and try
and recreate this physical system where
the templates are an emergent property
wouldn't it be better to do that
um
uh okay
so this is like uh where did these
templates come from basically
it's it's a
in a sense that's what you're asking
they must be an emergent property of our
physical reality
uh
it's one for all like this did not
happen individually
it could be it happened for a template
human and we've inherited all of it all
of us the same templates the the reason
i say that we're not allowed to have
them differently this is a key point
this is a key point and and and instance
based learning
is a completely opposite paradigm
it pay it's based on what i see and what
i observe these templates are not
susceptible to this weakness
so
so they could have been here's the thing
there was a template human an abstract
platonic human that learned these
templates and then we all inherited them
done
okay we're going really deep sci-fi here
but the reason i'm saying that is the
reason i'm saying that is we're not
allowed to learn them individually
you were going to make the assertion
that the templates would exist even if
the universe didn't exist and i don't
agree with that i think the templates
are are an emerging property of the
universe
do you think transitivity
gives to them if planet earth did not
exist
well you've got me on that one but the
logic of events certainly wouldn't exist
at the university okay
we can't quibble on which ones are can
live in the ether and in the universe at
large but the my point is there's a huge
number of fees that we're not allowed to
learn them differently
and we don't have time to learn them
we we just don't have time so
they are there somewhere where did they
come from how did they get how did we
all
acknowledge them
willingly or unwillingly we have no
choice i mean if we just
took them and we actually we function
based on them without even knowing
i agree and if there is if there was
another civilization on another planet
they would also
acquire the knowledge of events
right i mean that seems fairly obvious
to me yeah i can't see transitivity not
being true on any planet right or any
galaxy
the real problem from our point of view
is we want to create artificial general
intelligence and actually the problem is
one of representational primitives
you believe that we should design the
abstract categories to resemble the
emerging categories the universe gives
us
right even though there are almost
uncountably many of them you think
but there could be
some that are a composition of others so
right we we need to do at least the most
basic primitive ones
i made a reference in the latest article
i posted on my blog to uh
gordon and hobb's book on common sense
uh psychology
and they go through a lot of these and
they're coded actually in the list but
so we we have to code
these basic i don't know they could be
uh ten thousand of them but each one of
them is very simple and the logic of it
is quite simple
a an intelligent machine has to know
these things you can't function i mean
you you can't have a a an autonomous car
that doesn't know the basic logic of
contained in
and
there are so many of these
that a three-year-old functions based on
them without knowing you tell a little
kid
can you can you please put the uh laptop
in in my briefcase
oh dad it doesn't fit try to tell them
to put it in a smaller one they say what
you're tying with me like so a
three-year-old knows that
can doesn't fit this trans or bigger
than or smaller than inversely
and they function based on and we
function every day based on a lot of
these templates whether it's the logic
of events the logic of physical uh size
and chair
i cannot imagine learning these from
scratches what do you mean it's all from
data
no these high level templates we are
respecting how the universe works
we give we give each other too much
credit it's not all up to us very little
is up to us yan lacoon says that deep
learning models can perform discrete
reasoning and i just want to pick this
apart because i think what they mean
is they have this hash table or storage
view of neural networks and what you're
talking about the kind of reasoning
you're talking about doesn't require any
storage
right all you need is a function that
takes an input and it gives you an
output that could extrapolate anywhere
in experienced space right right and no
we don't that's the huge difference
we're now we conquered infinity with
that difference look i mean the
i might store a few things just out of
laziness sometimes we store them like
for example i have a few things that i
don't compute now like i and i i i
recall them from like from my i don't
know why i store these because maybe
they're most frequently asked of me so i
store them because i want to be lazy
here not to recompute them but
but to store everything it's this is
ridiculous i mean we
we re we recompute and but this there's
an implication by we compute not store
most of the stuff the big implication is
is a killer for the ml paradigm at least
the the current model
first the first killer is i have to have
symbols
yep there's no other way i can compute
stuff and not store them without symbols
second
there's a
there's a
there's a quantification and there's a
symbolic representation it's not just
the calculation it's symbolic i have
symbolic storage of intentional objects
infinite objects like addition i have an
algorithm and stored
yeah not not just a symbol and some
string in a table the implication is
huge that means i have
functions procedures intentional
descriptions
finite descriptions of infinite objects
what does it mean to have multiplication
in my head that means
i have an infinite hash table of
multiplication in my mind that i can
always produce i know but i think this
is even simpler than most people realize
it it just comes down to this computer
science trade-off of compute versus
storage
as an engineer i see it all the time
sometimes it's cheaper for me to cash
some computation and stick it in a hash
table and pull it on demand and
sometimes it's better for lazy
evaluation to compute something now that
we know how neural networks work they
are hash tables in input because i think
the problem is people think of neural
networks as having some kind of
computation
there's no computation
look the reason for that is yeah it took
me a while actually because the the
initial paradigm conveys
function computation because the neural
network in the end is a is a composition
of many fs at every layer i mean you you
think of a neural network as
f1 of f2 of f3 where every f is
computing each layer and the input of
this layer is now so it is thought of as
function composition and that
immediately gives you the impression
that
oh function composition that's like
that's a computation that's a program
well yes and no because the algorithm
and the intelligence
is in the data itself so in other words
it's it's different from symbolic
computation you're storing the logic and
what the data told you
in your architecture yeah people think
of it as a function composition but but
it's actually not
we used to think that it was performing
successive functions
actually every single input that goes
into neural network is definable with a
single affine transformation right right
because at the end in the end uh
function composition is a function
exactly and yeah but
you know what the functions are doing at
every layer
they're
they're building the keys in this
hashtag yes
that's that's called
it's a it's a it's a big hashing
function
yeah that that and then it's
and then your weights are the lookup so
basically what you're doing is you're
all these function compositions are
building
a very sophisticated hashkey yeah
it's all the key every single neuron in
a neural network is is um a hyperplane
which might be the face of the polyhedra
that that input example goes into so
every single neuron is a key
is a key is a key and
well
the key
there but there's a composite key so a a
certain input
might have
these neurons
right i mean i mean that's what the soft
max in the end figures out that okay
uh
the
this object has these neurons
contributing to its key
so you're uh uh you're you're a dog okay
so i i looked you up i fetched you and
there are some neurons that are gonna
determine
what you are so i looked you up
it's an unbelievable way of making
very smart fuzzy and the keys are fuzzy
by the way it comes into a trade-off
between approximation statistical and
optimization complexity versus
computation complexity because because
if you think about it and unlimited and
limited storage
that's right so what you're doing is
you're tesselating this euclidean space
and it's an exponentially large it's
very very large but the the reality that
we live in is infinitely large so
infinitely large is significantly bigger
than exponential exponential uh
euclidean space right there's no
comparison
right no comparison and when you add
the very sophisticated way of making
lookup keys
there's even more magic happening than
um that this is it this is why it's such
a powerful device and i'm not minimizing
it yeah but
but let's be safe let's not let's not
say this you know that's the only issue
i mean but it's um it's a brilliant way
of reducing
my
initial lookup is infinite like you said
it's it's then exponential but with
enough training and enough layers
especially the deepness it's
i am making a very sophisticated
sophisticated key where i can now look
you up
with high certainty of accuracy
it's amazing if you look at it but
to take that and say
agi
transferability which is
a huge thing that's being ignored in in
the community you know why we were just
talking when keith was here about the
architecture and the algorithm are
intertwined and the memory right so
transferability is almost impossible
like we you cannot because it's like
you're saying i wrote an algorithm that
will do everything
if you equate the algorithm like what no
there's in in symbolic computation i
have an algorithm that does this in a
neural network the architecture is your
algorithm
so
transfer what i mean what are you
talking about you have a universal
program that solves everything you can
the mathematician and keith got it if i
have an infinite neural network yes
because i can
inhibit certain part of the network for
one algorithm and then so it's like i
have all the algorithms in one
infinite neural network but that's
insane right yeah exactly the
interesting thing is that neural
networks work at all because there is
there is an infinite experience space
combinatorially large but there's
there's a lot of structure there here
here i have to give
i mean
really if anything
jeff hinton's touring award
is probably
worthy
the back propagation algorithm was a
huge invention
i mean to optimize
well there's the limitation of
differentiable
differentiability but
that aside
it's it's a genius i mean you will look
we're talking about building these keys
to do look up on unseen data
that's the magic so
it is
because that's where the magic happens
that's where you keep adjusting these
weights basically
you're you're improving on your keys on
on your lookup
function or if you want to think about
it
but it's genius if you think about the
but it has its limitation it's a
powerful powerful machine
back propagation is all about how do you
um move these basis functions these
hyper planes they're quite uniformly
spaced out in the input space so what
backpropagation actually does is it
changes all of the poses to chop up the
input space around your training data
chopping up is the key here
yeah it's the key so that chops up the
input space but that's on mlps and that
doesn't get you very far the deep
learning revolution has little to do
with uh back propagation it has a lot to
do with convolutional neural networks
has a lot to do with the relu function
it has a lot to do with all the cloud
computing revolutions okay actually data
activation yeah well the cloud computing
is performance and scaling i mean okay
i'm talking about which i'm talking
about
right but i'm talking about expressive
power as a paradigm i mean
yes activation functions there was a lot
of
advances in
like relu and all the new
methods of it's sort of similar to our
our computers are still von neumann
machines but they're nowhere near what
the initial von neumann machine was but
in terms of
it's not expressive power in terms of
what it can do
we're still in the same
the same
venn diagram in the same space yeah
the the technology improved not the
science i mean not the
if you want to compare them but
essentially it's the same paradigm
which was genius still is it has its
place
my only issue is when people start
saying
this this universal quantification it
will do everything
uh i don't need symbolic it's just
because i'm stuck with this
architecture that is
data-driven
and and when you talk about
self-supervision like what exactly do
you mean
we again we're back to blank slate
learning from uh
and
that's too extreme and i can't see in
many many problems not just language and
common sense
in many problems even like i said naive
physics
so uh but
the debate is fun the debate itself is
fun
because
we i hope we learn from each other but
it's fun always thank you